do you worry about AI AGI enabling a
dystopian state of this nature whether
it's 1984 with surveillance and fear or
Brave New World with
pleasure and what is it l lots of
sex but no deep Human
Experience you there's actually a real
drug called soma there is
yes
does Gro know about it no he probably
will go to Brave New World we could ask
it what what would be the question tell
us about the drug called soma tell us
about the drug called
s it's going to go to Brave New World I
think well there's a real drug as well
searching for S drug
information oh
boy ah s the wonder drug by the way I'm
in fun mode oh okay
yes so it's talking about the real drug
oh it's a muscle relaxing that's been
around since the 1950s it's used to
treat muscle pain and discomfort and it
does this by altering the activity
between neurons and the spinal cord now
Soma isn't just a pain reliever it's
also a bit of a sedative it can make you
feel a bit drowsy so it's not something
to take if you're planning on operating
heavy machinery or trying to solve
complex mouth equations and it goes on
and on in conclusion s is a drug that
can be helpful for those dealing with
muscle pain but it's not without its
risks it's pretty good oh wait a minute
that's the real drug it's talking about
it's the real drug yeah uh and of course
the fun is always use it responsibly in
accordance with the advice of a healthc
care professional and remember in the
end the universe is probably just a
giant computer simulation so don't take
anything too seriously I love I love it
I love it I love it yeah so oh it also
really nicely uh includes like uh the
the tweets post on X that that are
relevant to this which is really cool
yeah it like integrates everything
together yeah like the interface is one
of the really cool things here yeah
seems done a great job
um so and you say like you could say
like no I no I mean Soma from bra Brave
New World because it it thinks you mean
you you mean s the real drug yeah no I
mean s from bra beer
world it's gonna be like oops I'm really
sorry I'm really surprised who went to
the real drug
first ah my apologies I was thinking of
the muscle relax and Som for Brave New
World is a different Beast altogether
now do hux Le toop now Som is a drug
that plays a central role in the society
depicted in the book it's a mood
altering hucog genic drug that's used to
keep the population docile and content
in the novel to use S Brave New World
raises some interesting questions about
the nature of happiness and the role of
drugs and
Society oh man exactly is it better to
live in a world where everyone is happy
all the time even if that Happ happiness
is
artificial good question this is what I
mean like do you want do you wish for
world peace and and happiness all the
time are you sure mhm um because that
might be a society that is essentially
sterile and aifi that never changes that
is ultimately doomed
this kind of tension
between uh darkness and the
light really a very good summary um MH
it really gets to the point this is not
simply
regurgitating Brave New World it's
actually getting to the Salient element
of Soma as a drug um do you do you
actually want to be in a a situation
where everyone is happy all the time
even though it's artificial or is it
better to confront the challenges of
life and experience full range of human
emotions even if it means experiencing
pain and suffering for those listening
by the way Elon just read directly from
Gro which is a really nice kind of
insightful philosophical analysis of the
tension here interesting it pretty much
Nails it in conclusion s from Brave New
World is fictional drug that is used to
explore some deep philosophical
questions about the nature of happiness
and the role of drugs in society it's a
powerful symbol of the dangers of using
drugs to escape from reality and the
importance of confronting the challenges
of life head
on nailed
it and the crazy thing is like you know
we do have a real drug called soma which
kind of does is kind of like the drug in
the book and I'm like did they they must
have name they must have named it after
probably probably yeah some of the real
drug is quite effective on back pain so
you know about this drug is
fascinating okay cuz I had like a you
know squashed uh disc in my C5 C6 so it
takes the physical pain away way but s
here it doesn't completely it it it
reduces the amount of pain you feel but
at the expense of mental
acuity it DS your
mind just like just like the drug in the
book just like the drug in the book yeah
and hence the
trade-off uh the thing that seems like
Utopia could be a dystopia after all
yeah actually I was talking to a friend
of mine
um saying like would you really want
there to be no hate in the world like
really none like I wonder why hate
evolved um I'm not saying we should
amplify hate of course I think we should
try to minimize it but but none at
all H there might be a reason for
hate and suffering it's really
complicated to consider that some amount
of human suffering is necessary for
human
flourishing is it possible to appreciate
the highs without knowing the
lows
and that that that all is summarized
there in a single statement from grock
okay no highs no lows who
knows